oh go please let it be a match [ __ ] oh
god he's gonna see the match and get all
excited oh oh yeah yeah and then he's
gonna message me some cheesy pick-up
line thinking he's being creative oh
yeah yeah I can just pick Nora's message
that's it but what if I bump into him
somewhere oh god I'm sorry I'm so sorry
hey I know you
I'm I mastered you and you didn't
respond to any of my messages that
really hurt my feelings it's a very
thing to do I know I know I'm so sorry
well you can make it up to me now by
going out with me and they don't feel
like I have to go out with them because
women are so quickly judged us [ __ ]
when they are not interested which of
course is [ __ ] but I'm certainly not
immune to desire the pressures oh I
expect you'll be really nice on the
first date which will make me feel awful
to say no to a second but you'll
basically lead to us dating
[Music]
I guess that means I have to be his
parents it's so good to meet you and
obviously they'll love me so they'll
inviting me to their Christmas in Denver
and in every family vacation after that
they'll see how well I fit in with his
family and so eventually proposed will
you marry me or whatever my politeness
is not got me so far into the situation
I find myself blurting out yes yeah I
could always leave him at the altar but
I'm fairly sure my friends and family
would be super pissed at me I would have
to leave all my worldly Affairs behind
and go and live on a desert island and
become one with the sea creatures okay
so that part is just totally unrealistic
so I would marry him and then his family
would tell me that he's their only child
and only chance to keep the family name
going so I guess I have a kid with them
the kid will need a sibling to keep him
company so I guess we'll have to buy now
I'm in too deep so he raised two kids
become grandparents or not depending on
what I kiss aside they want from life
they're retiring about the rest of our
days on a boat sail around the
Mediterranean when we die I expect we'll
be buried together and how to so will
Express the deep love we had for one
another when all along it was a total
and utter sham but at least I wasn't
rude that's what I'll take with you when
I go oh there's a nun match button
[Music]
hungry
[Music]
[Music]